une vingtaine d'associations et de
services spécialisés en santé publique
mobilisée à Saint-Quentin du 5 au 8 juin
l'opération est baptisée forum santé
c'est la 9e édition elle se déroule une
fois encore à l'espace Saint-Quentin à
Montigny le Bretonneux bonsoir marine
vraiment marcheuse vous êtes la
directrice de l'Institut de promotion de
la santé basée à Trappes et bonsoir
Daniel Viala vous êtes délégué à la
santé pour la communauté d'agglomération
de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
précisez-nous tout d'abord quel est le
constat qui vous a poussé à mettre en
place ce forum santé qui fête sa 9e
édition quel était le constat de départ
il fallait aller rencontrer justement
peut-être les citoyens et parler de leur
santé parce que c'est pas si évident et
de peut-être des dramatiser en fait
certaines maladies notamment là c'est
sûr que dans sa forme santé quand on
parle de malade d'Alzheimer quand on
parle de cancer quand on parle de
maladie invalidantes de sida
ça paraît ça paraît étrange mais en fait
c'est permettre la rencontre de
professionnels ou de d'associations avec
une la population qui n'oserait pas elle
est directement les rencontrer les gens
que vous rencontrez dans le centre
commercial lors du Forum ce sont des
gens que vous ne voyez pas le reste de
l'année à l'IPS ou dans d'autres
rendez-vous de santé oui
ça fait peur on pense que le les
professionnels sont loin qu'ils sont
dans une espèce de tour d'ivoire qui ne
parle pas le même langage qu'on va pas
pouvoir s'exprimer correctement on a
d'ailleurs les personnes qui viennent
sur les stands souvent disent j'ai à une
amie j'ai une cousine j'ai quelque chose
qui
et puis au fur et à mesure alors bien
sûr les stands sont pas là pour non plus
pour écouter jusqu'au bout c'est leur
permettre de faire le pas et d'aller
après vers l'association ou d'aller vers
le service qui qui leur permettra d'être
aidé est-ce que c'est véritablement
efficace quel bilan vous pouvez faire
des précédentes éditions
mais en tout cas vous voyez les
retombées ensuite sur les différents les
associations nous le disent notamment la
première association qui nous le dit le
plus le plus fréquemment c'est France
Alzheimer qui trouve des bénévoles
d'ailleurs en plus pour aussi les aider
et qui aussi rencontrent des familles en
difficulté qu'il n'auraient pas osé
faire le pas et qu'ils l'ont fait à ce
moment-là et elle rencontre aussi des
familles d'autres
horizons c'est à dire d'autres
départements et donc les liens sont
faits avec les autres
associations de France Alzheimer des
dans les autres départements le forum
qui se déroule du Synco 8 juin l'accent
est mis sur le diabète l'alimentation
les accidents domestiques l'hygiène
corporels les addictions comment se
déroule justement ce forum ce sont des
professionnels qui interviennent qui
échange avec ce public ça peut être des
professionnels ou des bénévoles en
fonction donc des des stands qui sont
qui sont tenus certains seront donc
tenus par des associations bénévoles
d'autres seront tenus par des
associations mais des associations de
professionnels ayant des professionnels
certains également le seront avec des
101 centre hospitaliers on a aussi un
centre de recherche par exemple autour
du handicap enfin voilà et chacun tourne
c'est à dire que on ne trouvera pas tous
les jours les mêmes mais chacun tourne
et cette année on a une nouveauté on a
l'assurance maladie qui vient travailler
avec nous et présenter donc ces ateliers
santé actives présentées également des
nouveaux logiciels qu'il propose aux
patients et donc voilà donc c'est un
intéressant aussi de voir que
l'assurance maladie vient un vrai
partenaire de ce rendez-vous juste pour
conclure sur les rendez-vous qui sont
proposés lors de ces journées 5 au 8
juin à l'espace Saint-Quentin c'est à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il y a un saut en
particulier il y a un accent particulier
qui sera mis sur le la formation aux
soins et la perte d'autonomie aussi je
voulais juste m'attarder sur ce point-là
et le préciser parce que l'accent est
mis là-dessus cette année tout à fait
avec donc la présence de de réseau comme
karmaad la présence de gérondicap nous
aurons également
des des invités des jeunes infirmiers en
fait qui sont étudiants en soins
infirmiers qui pourront également
présenter leur travail présenter donc
leur activité notamment donc auprès des
personnes âgées etc et oui nous avons
plusieurs partenaires qui parlent de la
dépendance qui parlent des soins qui
parlent et qui parlent du cursus aussi
donc pour arriver à des métiers un peu
particuliers ce rendez-vous est proposé
par les PS vous l'avez compris c'est
piloter donc par la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
quelle place occupe la santé au sein de
cette politique de la communauté
d'agglomération
la preuve que c'est
occupe une place importante c'est que
c'est une donc uniquement santé que je
représente donc ce soir et la politique
de santé c'est quelque chose qui est
ancré dans la réflexion du territoire
déjà depuis de nombreuses années au
travers de la politique de la ville et
par la mise en place d'un certain nombre
de structures et de relations
structures c'est l'IPS par exemple et
les relations c'est toutes les relations
partenariales qui existent avec les
associations que le docteur vraiment
marcher sovi de cité mais qui existe
également avec des institutions comme la
CEPAM donc dont on vient de parler
également et également avec le Conseil
Général qui finance un certain nombre de
structures et de et de missions sur le
sur le territoire notamment on vient de
citer gérontica c'est très important les
handicap on a eu déjà l'occasion d'en
parler ensemble c'est une structure qui
qui réunit en un seul lieu tout ce qui
peut concourir à la lutte contre la
dépendance des personnes donc à
l'autonomie prolongée des personnes chez
elles et
toutes ces tous ces partenariats toutes
ces relations montrent l'importance que
la santé a dans la réflexion du
territoire mais traité de la
problématique de la santé c'est pas
forcément une chose évidente sur un
bassin comme celui de 50 ans en Yvelines
déjà le département est assez justement
disparate et les populations sont très
différentes ça se retrouve aussi à 50
ans en ligne on parle pas des mêmes
questions de santé
le territoire de 51 en Yvelines est un
territoire qui est à l'image de la
société donc on y trouve en effet des
populations qui vont avoir des besoins
différents d'un endroit à l'autre et
puis des populations aussi en fonction
de leurs âges qui vont pas avoir non
plus les mêmes les mêmes besoins c'est
le rôle de l'IPS et donc de que ces
données la communauté d'agglomération
dans le cadre de la santé de faire en
sorte qu'il y a un maillage entre tous
ces toutes ces structures toutes ces
associations tous ces bénévoles qui
travaillent pour le bien-être des
habitants donc forcément de répondre à
toutes problématique de santé où il y a
certains populations et c'est on a
vraiment un travail de tous les instants
Marilyn et moi on travaille en très
bonne intelligence sur le sur le terrain
on se on se partage certaines activités
et puis le territoire il ne faut pas
l'oublier et ville OMS donc c'est quand
même un critère qui a été octroyé au
territoire parce que très certainement
la politique santé qui était menée le
méritait et depuis octobre nous avons
même été retenus au conseil
d'administration de l'OMS et même au
bureau de classification organisation
mondiale de la santé ça se traduit par
l'application des chartes qui ont été
signés par l'OMS et notamment qui montre
que la santé c'est pas l'absence de
maladie la santé c'est être bien être
bien c'est quoi c'est être bien dans son
dans sa ville être bien
parce que la ville vous offre
des loisirs mais vous offre aussi les
structures liées à l'école vous offre
aussi un environnement agréable tout ça
aussi c'est ça la définition de la santé
en fait c'est être le mieux possible
dans tous les éléments qui font votre
vie en fait et l'être le plus longtemps
possible c'est pour ça que je faisais le
lien tout à l'heure avec Jérôme
spécifiques à cette communication c'est
peut-être pas le terme mais
labellisation
2012 un colloque national qui s'est
déroulée à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et
qui a réuni quand même plus de 200
partenaires plus de 200 personnes qui
sont venues assister à ce coloc et là
nous avons
concouru on va dire pour le colloque
alors là à un autre niveau puisque c'est
plus international le colloque des
villes santé francophones et les 51 en
Yvelines a été retenu et donc en fin
2014 il y aura donc en coloc
international des villes francophones
avec un intérêt particulier puisque si
on voit par exemple le Canada a
développé dans certaines branches des
actions que nous nous n'avons pas encore
peut-être travailler suffisamment la
Belgique également et puis les villes
les villes francophones d'Afrique qui
seront présentes également nous
apporterons leur expérience leur leur
expérience totalement différentes de
celles de nos territoires mais que l'on
peut peut-être aider aussi par la
réflexion que nous on a déjà menée et
donc toute cette toutes ces rencontres
tous ces échanges dans le cadre de la
recherche du bien-être des habitants
voilà c'est ça qui mène
la réflexion et l'action la rencontrer
échange il y en aura forcément lors du
Forum de santé du 5 au 8 juin je reviens
juste au sujet difficile peut-être à
aborder c'est quoi les sujets difficiles
abordés quels sont-ils est-ce qu'il y a
ça lors des formes par exemple parce que
ce sera quand même dans un lieu
particulier c'est un espace commercial
donc bien sûr mais les sujets qui
peuvent paraître difficile c'est
justement ce que j'ai dit dès le début
du reportage c'est vraiment les sujets
comme le cancer la mort le sida des
choses comme ça il y a pas de limite
vous vous autorisez aborder tous ces
sujets
nos partenaires le font donc nous
pouvons le faire ils viennent et chaque
année on voit à quoi c'est
utile de faire ce genre d'action et ce
que je ne m'a pas dit tout à l'heure
aussi c'est que de plus en plus nous
travaillons également alors là c'est
plus en termes de soins mais nous
travaillons de plus en plus également
avec l'ensemble des centres hospitaliers
du temps qui fonctionne sur le
territoire mais aussi en périphérie et
l'ensemble des libéraux donc de plus en
plus on a aussi une réflexion avec en
fait ce que nous ce que moi on me
demande en tout cas c'est d'avoir
vraiment un travail à la fois de terrain
le plus proche possible de la population
ça c'était aussi un travail que nous
faisons avec les communes avec les
différents services des communes de
façon à développer au plus proche de la
population et puis un autre travail qui
est un travail de de maillage et de
réseautage avec des partenaires et
notamment que nous n'avons pas cité on a
cité le Conseil général mais aussi
l'Agence Régionale la santé donc voilà
nous travaillons et tout ça donc c'est
vraiment un maillage à la fois j'allais
dire politique mais aussi d'action
justement puisqu'on parle de politique
une dernière question pour pour conclure
en ces temps économique difficile est-ce
que la politique de santé est remise en
cause ce qu'il y a des budgets qui sont
limités supprimés pour l'IPS par exemple
on a pas l'agglomération conserve les
mêmes priorités concernant la santé
c'est une priorité à laquelle on tient
merci à toutes les deux je redonne les
dates de ce forum santé neuvième édition
du 5 au 8 juin centre commercial Espace
50 ans Montigny-le-Bretonneux merci à
vous